many thanks alistair
i wouldn't want to organize by anybody
anybody else but you so
so
like many talks in this symposium i'll
start with
the father of our field because
during alan turing was the first
computer scientist he was also the first
computer scientist to wield
the lens uh and
by this i mean what has been uh
said many times in this these three days
that it turns out also we think
that the computational thinking that we
developed especially theoretical
computer science is developed
over the past 60 years in order to
understand this beast
the computer and then this other bigger
beast the internet
turned out to be very useful when
applied to uh
everything else other realms of science
and this this
today i'm going to tell you about
evolution and by evolution you shouldn't
think of
darwin alone because much happened
before and after darwin
and perhaps you didn't know that
evolution was going on you know it was
it was a mainstream thought that
had been going on for at least a century
before darwin
so much that one of the great
evolutionary thinkers before darwin was
darwin's own grandfather
erasmus uh another great evolutionist
before dharmi of course was
uh jean-baptiste lamarck uh who was
perhaps the greatest physiologist of the
of the uh
of the era of the 1800s
except that he he is remembered
by his only mistake uh namely that that
that characters can be acquired
characters can be heard which he has
very little very little uh uh
uh blame uh because uh apparently it was
uh
very strange curiously very widespread
belief
in uh among french peasants at the time
okay that this had observed this
again before darwin i mean this talk is
about computer scientists thinking about
evolution so it's very striking that the
grand grandfather
of the computer of our field charles
babbage
was one of the great evolutionary
thinkers of his time
and he didn't say that but he said
something that really amounts to that
and he said it around 1820 that god did
not create species but created
the algorithm for created species which
of course
is ranks as a very nice try
okay
then came the origin of species uh the
origin of species did not
uh give the idea of evolution did not
offer the word the idea of evolution
this was
quite mainstream as i said but
uh
offered the the new contributions were
two things the
natural selection which is pro was
proposed as a driving force defining
evolution
and common ancestry which darwin was the
first
naturalist to propose this as as that we
all come from a few species he said he
meant one
the berkeley department of rhetoric used
to teach
you know i have taught it in in a
graduate class i i thought
but the berkeley partner of rhetoric
used to teach the origin of species
because the origin is
perhaps the world's most masterful piece
of scientific rhetoric okay
it's the most compelling argument you
will ever read okay so so if
if you haven't read it you should read
it
and in fact there is uh darwin kept kept
changing it over over the years and
there are six editions during his
lifetime
in fact you can find the web veritable
phylogenetic three of these six editions
okay
basically with uh analyzing the
difference between the between various
and the most interesting of which
of the parameters that they are being
analyzed is
the number of mentions of the word god
which which is basically
it is it is a harmonic of two
and uh and uh you realize i know
harmonic of two
means means internal conflict okay so
that's
famous you know almost as famous as as
as the origin is the wallace darwin
debate
uh as you know the
great another great naturalist scooped
darwin he came up
with uh with the the idea of natural
selection
in 1958 and he wrote
this he wrote a letter from malaysia
to darwin announcing this and darwin
reacted with impeccable academic
integrity and he organized
a debate in which the two papers were
read
and in darwin's paper i mean he was
frantically
editing the last version of the origin
at the time
darwin's paper is three pages what the
reason i'm mentioning especially is that
is that there is a computer science
there is a very mainstream computer
science idea there
that he devotes half of his paper
believe it or not
into defining and explicating uh
exponential growth okay now if you talk
to your aunt about exponential growth
she will interrupt you after a second
and will not okay so you know she knows
what it is
but i mean but to the most clever the
scientific elite
of the victorian of victorian england uh
darwin had to
explain it in two pages okay so uh and
uh
first of all he was uh he was influenced
by that from economist malthus
and and the reason why exponential
growth was important in his argument
was that after you understand what
exponential explosion means
darwin goes on to say how come we don't
see
this is what is predicted by by
multiplication of species you know by
by progeny why how come we don't
see it in life and the
reason is that life is hard and only the
feet survive okay so that
is sort of the beginning of his argument
okay
um brilliant argument of course
a lot of things were uh you know most
you know most of most of things were
left unasked
for example how do new ideas in
evolution arise okay
and uh darwin says in about 10
a dozen places in in in
the uh uh origin of species that he does
not understand sex okay so
this is uh it it's still a mystery i
mean you still don't understand it
you know i'll come back to that
after darwin perhaps the greatest
biologist
of the 19th century is uh is a
wise man called uh as it happens wiseman
who made an incredible
statement in in 1980
1880 that the mapping from genotype to
phenotype is one way
he didn't say that okay but but he
really did okay so uh
and and uh if you think about it this is
sort of you know the final
nail on la marquez okay so that's uh
then genetics came okay so uh gregor
mendel
founded you know discovered a lot of
genetics working on peace
and i know we are all scientists who are
all eager to have our uh
the impact of our of our work and do you
know how many citations this the problem
arguably one of the 10 most important
papers in history of science
had three citations the first and i have
not read these papers but
those who have tell me that these three
folks didn't get it
okay so
then uh but then what happened is that
35 years later
uh man the work of mendel became
very well known it was another extremely
compelling argument
very persuasive much more scientific and
you know incidentally
that's a historical moment that's the
first time when math
well fractions that's math okay you know
where it was were used
were used in in in evolution
and but but on the surface
it appeared that mendel and darwin were
at loggerheads okay so you know
because darwin implicitly talked about
continuous threat
traits and mendel talked about green
flowers or yellow flowers and white
flowers
discrete traits okay so so it seemed
that they were talking about different
things
and the biologists are divided between
medallions of darwinians
geneticists and biometricists and so on
and
if you are a mathematician and you want
an extra reason to be proud for your
field
here is one okay here is a an important
one that that mathematics
saved the theory of evolution okay that
that three great mathematicians
three great mathematicians fisher wright
and haldane
uh came up with the equations that
reconciled
the mendelian view and and the darwinian
view
and these equations essentially say
that we have genes mendel said that
but also these genes the interaction of
multiple genes can create continuous
traits you know that's essentially what
what what they said and and
i'll come back to that to explain their
mathematical theory it's very rudiments
later in my talk uh big questions remain
i mean
how does novelty arise here here's what
i mean by this question uh
biologists now they have there is a
there are a couple of beautiful papers
that explain
how from a primitive eye you can get to
the falcons eye
okay so you know through sort of you
know uh
a few hundred mutations and uh and uh
what is less clear is how from no i you
get an
eye okay you know this is this is this
what i mean by novelty
and also the role of sex sex has been
called the queen of problems in
evolution because it's a mystery the
mystery in the sense
why is it ubiquitous okay why why is it
that
that all species multiply uh
sexually okay and and and uh and they do
okay i mean
if you look at the tree of life there is
no sexual species here there is a sexual
species here and there are sexual
species there
and there are very few far in between
and in fact
their ancestral species were sexual and
they lost it
okay so so so it's it's uh it's very
striking
and sex it seems to have a lot of
disadvantages i mean
here i'll just give you one of the one
of these advantages
as an example so imagine that you are
the perfect
human okay so you know you have the
perfect gene for for uh
liver the perfect gene for brain the
perfect gene for bones the perfect gene
for skin okay
so you are going to live 200 years and
have a hundred
children all right i mean the point is
that all of them will be deeply
imperfect because you will not find
another perfect
person to to to multiply with to to
have a child with and uh other reasons
or you know
you will be you know for some reason
it's very tragic it sounds very tragic
okay you know it's
you'll be a great idea that was lost
forever okay you know so
and it will never happen again okay so
uh
whereas in a sexual species if this
happens then the special
sexual species has made it forever okay
so you know it's going it's going to
conquer the world
so uh so why is that i mean why why
why does why does sex which destroys
great combinations
so another thing that
that peop many people have thought of
thought about evolution
not all of them all of them
uh biologists marcos suggested had an
extremely serious uh
interesting evolution uh he
basically said i don't believe i don't
believe that
that we have explained evolution and uh
uh if you uh if
if you remember
uh uh darwin
uh disbelieved evolution okay so you
know so he said
uh in here in the letter if you now
stare me into the eye and you ask me do
you really believe that the eye evolved
uh i will lower my eyes i will not
answer okay so um
so uh
and in fact there is a there is an
algorithmic version
uh to state the same the same disbelief
what algorithm could have could have
achieved
all these in a mere three in a mere
trillion steps okay
because that's how many generations we
had since eve
and uh and uh a trillion steps may say
you may think too many steps okay so you
know but if you think about it
this is how many steps your cell phone
has done since the beginning of my talk
okay so a trillion steps is not many
steps these days okay
uh i know there is parallelism involved
in evolution sure
okay so the whole number of generations
in all species
is comparable to the number of steps
all uh cell phones in the world make in
one minute
okay so it's not it's not very much okay
so so you know it's it's really amazing
and it's it's fair to ask what algorithm
could have achieved this
uh what may come as a surprise to you is
that
in the end of my talk i have an answer
okay we have found out which algorithm
it is
okay and it's not going to you know okay
so uh
not the fft okay it's something else
a great computer scientist who thought
about thinking hard about the evolution
is
less valiant and he
had his own his own version of disbelief
how do you find a three billion long
string in three billion years okay
and uh to answer this he came up with a
beautiful theory of
vulvability in which he connected
brilliantly the
the the revolution with uh
learning okay essentially showed that uh
evolution there is much much more
richness to this theory but one of the
results is that
uh evolution is a kind of statistical
learning
another way that computational evolution
have interacted is
through through
heuristics okay because evolution has
been
the the inspiration for a
very popular kind of heuristic called
the uh genetic algorithm
and the genetic algorithm what it does
so i assume that most of you know what
it does
uh i hope you are not great aficionados
because i'm not going to be kind to to
to genetic algorithms in this talk okay
you know so uh
uh uh the to solve an optimization
problem what you do
is you encode the sol the the solutions
okay let's say the trouble is there's no
problem you encode
tools are genomes okay of an organism
and then you have these
you have a population of these organisms
genomes
and then you the next generation is
produced by
such genomes marrying and exchanging
genetic information
except that the success with which they
procreate in other words the number of
expected numbers of children are going
to have and that's important in general
for the mathematics
i'm going to tell you is proportional
to how good a solution this is okay so
you know so their objective function is
essentially
their fitness all right and
through this simulation is through this
simulation of
of of population genetics through
to mimic an optimization problem
you hope that in the final population
eventually you are going to have some
amazing solutions okay
okay and there is
another idea inspired by asexual
evolution
uh simulated annealing i mean its name
is is a
late misnomer uh but i mean this idea
was called evolution since the 50s okay
so this this idea of heuristic
and basically the idea is that you
you have you have a genome
which corresponds to a solution and you
mutate it uh with probability increasing
with
the fitness with a fitness differential
and the objective differential subscript
and
now after you have this uh the mystery
of sex depends what do you mean by that
that simulated annealing which
corresponds to a sexual revolution works
just fine
uh in the sense that there are
practitioners who swear by it
and will not use anything else and there
are problems
where many approaches have been used and
simulated annealing
has has percolated on top
whereas genetic algorithms i don't know
how many friends
friends i lose i'm losing with this
slide don't work okay
face it they don't work okay what what
what i mean by that is the following
that i'm not aware of a single
computational problem for which many
approaches have been tried seriously and
and the genetic algorithm emerged
triumphant okay
and this is very strange okay this is
very strange why because in nature the
opposite happens okay
that sex is successful and ubiquitous
and
asexual organisms in other words the
ones who follow
this strategy the first strategy is
are the exception okay are there very
rare exceptions
so what on earth is going on here okay
so here is the radical thought uh it's
erratic i thought that occurred to to
adil if not in me
about six years ago uh what if sex
is a mediocre optimizer okay what if sex
40 optimization is not what sex is
supposed to do
what is sex optimizes something else and
what is something else is uh it's a
result
okay so this is this is what this is our
uh uh
uh initial thought and by god we find it
i mean
with with uh with uh uh marcus feldman
from
from stanford another biologist
who came up with this concept of some
mixability
which basically it
says that simulations demonstrate
that the answer that natural selection
under asex optimizes fitness
this is the easiest exercise in
dynamical systems okay of course
optimizing fitness we know that
that's trivial but under sex it
optimizes mixability it does not
optimize fitness it optimizes something
else
mixability mixability is the ability of
alleles
by this of course i mean gene variants
to perform well
with a broad spectrum of other alleles
let me explain and in explaining i'm
going to introduce the
fissure right model of population
genetics in a toy organism
this you know i know organisms are not
like that so imagine that you have a
two gene a haploid organism right i mean
it has only two genes
all one copy of these genes and
basically
the rows here are alleles of gen1
the columns are alleles of the other
gene
and the entries are the fitness by
fitness i mean
think of it as the expected number of
progeny
this uh the the number of times this uh
this particular
uh organism genome is going to
successfully made okay in order in order
in order to produce a child
and
then it's very trivial that
asex will select the biggest numbers in
this matrix okay
no doubt about that and in fact you know
the the population will flooded with
seventh
and eighths and eventually only by
eights okay
so and and therefore the best you know
the best will will survive
the fittest will survive except that
with sex what will be selected
is the rows and columns with the largest
average
okay and uh uh i'm cheating here because
when i say the loss of
colors the right in the largest average
i don't mean i mean i know
now you're busy averaging this okay uh i
what i mean is the largest average in
the current mix
okay under the current probability
distribution the current
um sort of allele three are little
frequencies in the population
okay uh so
uh let's let's change let's change the
subject all right
so i'll come back to to this uh
pointer dogs i don't know how many of
you know about pointer dogs pointer dogs
are dogs that
that whenever there is life in the in
the environment they would point to it
okay so
in this room a pointer dog would go
crazy okay right so yeah so uh
uh i don't know if you know how the
point of those
dogs you get pointer dogs okay darwin
was
obsessed with pointer dogs and actually
he was befriending the
shady characters in west london where
pointer dogs are being bred okay we're
being bred
and what uh the way the reason the way
that
you breathe point the box is the
following and i'm not kidding you okay
that's true
they you you get a few good hounds
and you you train them to point
and then you pick the best pointers
from the bunch and you bring them and
you take the puppies and you train them
to point
and you do this for a few generations
and lo and behold
puppies are born who point
happens okay so darwin was really
you know was naturally worried about
this okay you know he should be all
right you know so um
uh so this this particular point the dog
points to uh
wadecton okay so uh uh waddington is one
of the great experimentalists of the
university of ander in
the world of the 90 of the 20th century
and uh i'll tell you an experiment he
did
a famous experiment okay
he took a bunch of lies in
room temperature and uh raise the
temperature okay to tropical
uh and uh notice that 15
of them changed okay something subtle
changed in their wings okay so but let's
say their head became red okay
uh just just so so i can show you in my
slides okay so uh
15 changed and he
completed it for a few generations then
suddenly
in the uh in the fifth generation
60 changed
okay it went up then he continued like
that
63 64 65 after 20 generations
all of them can change okay
he kept of course the temperature high
now he did something amazing can you
guess
he lowered the temperature can you guess
what happened
that's amazing
okay uh so that's called genetic
assimilation
adaptations of the environment becomes
genetic okay
so that's that's the ghost of lamarck
right
now
there is a there is a generic
explanation so let's see what
suppose that we want to have a
mathematical generic explanation what
what is it that you are looking for
we are looking for a function it's a
boolean function
of uh 10 genes and
let's say and and and an environmental
variable
let's say h
so so that if you sample from an initial
distribution of genes
uh the probability that f is 1 is is
minuscule but if you raise the
temperature
it becomes significant and
if you breathe those it sometimes jumps
to 60
or thereabouts and if you continue
breathing
it becomes the property becomes
ubiquitous
but then if you turn uh h is back to
zero
it falls to something like 25 percent
can you find a function like that
and it's not hard to find a function
like that imagine that the function is
the sum of 10 bits plus three times the
sum of another bit
okay has to be greater than 10 let's say
and if you think about it for a second
so you know it's
it's uh it's a trivial calculation that
all that the ziterata
of of uh weddings or experiments are
are uh satisfied actually
an american naturalist called stern uh
came up with something like that uh uh
65 years ago in a journal called
american naturalist okay so uh
but the reason why i showed you this is
because it's tempting to try to
generalize it to
to to arbitrary boolean function okay
remember one of the
one of the one of the questions that i
posed is
how does novelty arise okay so
suppose that we have this suppose that
you have an arbitrary boolean function
and there is no environmental variable
and suppose that the satisfying
genotypes in other words the satisfying
to the assignments
have some fitness advantage okay let's
say they have one plus epsilon fitness
in other words they multiply a little
more successfully than others
will this trade be fixed eventually okay
and uh we have an answer the answer
turns out to be yes okay it's a
difficult theorem
uh it's uh any boolean function
of genes which confers in the
evolutionary advantage
there are technical details for example
we don't know how to do it unless it's
an evolutionary advantage like this
one versus one plus epsilon uh
will be eventually fixed with high
probability
uh that's uh joining work with uh ideal
if not
avid rubinstein greg valiant and andrew
andrew one
sorry wa huh
okay so uh
which to my mind means that to sex all
moderate size boolean functions are
evolvable
notice the following that
unlike most talk about evolution that
you'll hear i never mess with mutations
here
okay mutations are extremely important
okay these
the mutations are the things that create
the alleles okay
and most of evolutionary thought
justifiably
focuses on mutations what i'm presenting
to you
is is uh
my thoughts about our thoughts about
what happens
between these rare events okay how does
how does population genetics
maintain and and get the best
out of this variety of variation uh
created by uh
uh by the mutations okay
and notice that you
you know you don't hear about such you
know
when i say fischerian propagation is
this how
we have been taught to think about
evolution that there is a lucky mutation
because it creates uh strong organisms
it spreads through the population and
finally everybody has it okay so you
know that's
it's fixed that's that's what fischerian
propagation means this is
something completely different you know
it is basically
the working
through the frequencies through the in
the in the gene soup
of the population you have a force
that in the end
fixes a particular genotype okay or
fixes a particular clash of genotypes
the ones that satisfy this
truth assignment so in other words you
have a
sort of you know a more is different so
you know you have you have sort of you
know
a property that emerges in some sense
through the through the through the
population by
subtle manipulation of the statistics of
genes okay so it's
something that it's not unheard of but
it's not what the way that that we
usually think in evolution all right
different subject neutral theory this is
a very very
uh influential i just want to mention to
you because because what i'm going to
tell you next actually
in many ways what i told you before they
remember the one and one plus epsilon
neutral theory means that you don't see
huge differences
like zero and eight in the genome okay
so you know in the fitness
basically uh most of what happens in
evolution
with exceptions i mean we're not talking
now
bacteria bacteria
developing uh antibiotic resistance okay
so you know but but we are talking about
so you know ordinary evolution
you uh proceeds not by leaps upward but
by horizontally so you know by random
drift
uh and by small differences of interest
and weak selection is the mathematical
the mathematical uh
projection of this that says that the
value of the of the mid
of the fitness matrix are very close
let's say one minus epsilon one plus
epsilon
okay unlike the matrices that i showed
you before
okay uh i want to change the subject for
a minute okay
and then tell you about uh uh
the experts problem how many of you know
the express program
okay so you are in for for for a trip
okay
you know this this is this amazing uh
mathematical
mathematical fact it's so amazing that
people
keep discovering it and forgetting about
it and discovering it again and
forgetting about it okay so you know it
has it has happened five times okay you
know so
so here here is this and now you know so
the reason why
why i'm why i'm telling you this way is
because now you will never forget okay
and civilization will never rotate again
okay so so that's uh
so here is here here is here is a very
simple very simple uh
uh uh situation every day of the year
you must select one of n advisors there
are and
think of them as financial advisors okay
they give you financial advice
every day okay one of them says buy
french bonds okay another one says
sell your holdings in in
this company okay and so on right
and the next day
you open the wall street journal and you
see how each one of them did
okay and if you are lucky you chose the
one who gave you the best advice
but probably not okay because in the
beginning you have zero information
so and you could continue this for every
day of the year okay
now one of the things that you should
should bear in mind okay so you know
that and i'm coming back to to to our
old friend the adversary sorry
during this conference okay that uh uh
a prankster is uh is presenting you you
both
with with uh both with uh the advice
and the wall street uh publication okay
in other words
somebody's trying to embarrass you okay
somebody
is trying sort of you know to tell you
you are stupid you
have chosen this person and now you are
true you chose that okay so so in other
words it's a very adversary think of it
as a way it's it's
productive to think of it not as a
random situation but as an adversarial
situation
and your goal is uh
so sorry the advice over expert results
in a gain
which is either between minus one and
one okay so either you lose something or
you win something
but so we know these these numbers are
chosen are chosen uh adversarially okay
uh somebody a prankster is choosing for
them to for you to
to embarrass you and the challenge is
you want in the end of the 365 days in
the end of the year
to have done as well
as the best expert okay in the end of
the year one of the one of the experts
would have done
the best of all you want to have picked
every day this expert well
not every day but but you have what you
want to do essentially as well
i know it sounds completely impossible
okay so
it's extremely surprising that it's
possible okay
it can be done that's why that's the
reason why
it has been discovered and forgotten a
few times
uh it was it was uh uh
discovered by an economist in 58 by tom
cover
in the in the context of financial
mathematics in 1980
it was uh it was discovered in the 80s
as the wino algorithm as boosting
algorithm
as uh no regret learning in in in game
theory
and uh as the multiplicative weights
update algorithm okay so you know so
uh it's affectionately called
mua okay you know when when you when you
pronounce it you should sound like an
animal
okay okay
so what does this algorithm do
it does the following extremely simple
you know the algorithm is so simple
and the proof is so simple that it makes
no sense that this is so contrary to
that this fact is so counterintuitive
okay so
initially you assigned to all experts
the same probability of course you are
going to use randomness i mean
this is this is what you do to
adversaries right
and then at each step you increase the
weight
of each of each
expert essentially by
one plus a small multiple of how much
you would get out of them how well they
did that particular day
okay that's that's the whole algorithm
and for those of you who are quick with
math you realize that one plus epsilon
is basically a guys for e to the right
and therefore in the exponents of the
weights you now have the sum you carry
the sum
right of the performance of
uh every expert and as a result
eventually you will always choose the
best expert with overwhelming
probability
and if there are ties between experts
there are ties for good reason because
they're equally well
they're doing equally well so there is
so you there is no way that you can lose
this is the this is the safest thing to
do okay that's an amazing algorithm
uh it's uh what um what is
even more amazing is that uh
in uh if you program it as an algorithm
okay as a not not as not as a way to
choose experts but as a
as an algorithm it solves
a lot of sophisticated problems which it
had no right to hope to solve
okay for example it's all zero sum games
linear programming complex programming
network congestion so it's
sort of a miraculous algorithm okay so
it's not
and computer scientists
find it hard to believe that this
completely sophisticated extremely
simple to state extremely simple to
prove algorithm
has this amazing behavior okay and
of course there are there is the other
disbelief that i've talked about okay
that
you know how come all this came
out of this very primitive natural
selection uh
mechanism and uh what i want to
to tell you is a theorem that we proved
recently we presented it at
itcs the conference earlier this year
that under weak selection the regime
that i mentioned before which is which
is widely accepted to be
uh uh the prevalent
uh way of understanding evolution of
the understanding the way that the
revolution has proceeded
uh especially in the in the wake of the
molecular biomolecular bible
revolution because we have seen how
much diversity exists in in the genomes
of species
so evolution of species
is a game okay i have to explain okay i
say theorem
and then i start with a completely
informal statement okay
here's what i mean i mean that the
populations of
of of of uh sorry the equations of
population genetics
as as
invented by proposed by fisher and
wright
and has used for the last 90 years as
essentially the dominant way of
understanding evolution
mathematical rigorous way of
understanding evolution that the same
equations
under the weak selection assumption
are tantamount to a repeated game
okay it's a game between genes
okay so what the players are the genes
okay
the strategies of the gene everything
has a much bunch of strategies these are
the alleles
okay as you know from game theory
a player may randomize between
strategies do genes randomize of course
they randomize
how do they randomize the randomized
strategy is basically the frequency
of uh sorry uh the
the the problems are the frequency of
the alleles in the population
okay every game must have a utility what
are the utilities of the players
the answer here is extremely simple all
players have the same utility
so this is not the selfish gene
hypothesis of dawkins okay so you know
this is also the community-minded gene
okay
all genes have the same
have the same utility their interests
are completely aligned
and they are aligned with the interest
of the organism okay
all the genes want to do was to maximize
the fitness of the organism
okay and so that's a coordination game
you know in in in in game theory
coordination games are
of course the easiest most trivial kind
of game
the only challenge there is to see is is
that is that perhaps
the players are cognitively challenged
to put this way and they cannot sort of
agree on the right
on the right they cannot communicate
they have no language they have no
communication they cannot agree
so and this i said this is a repeated
game
and how's the game repeated uh the game
is played through multiplication updates
so what they you know the
the the what the genes do
is uh they look at their alleles as
experts
okay and they weigh their probabilities
according to their performance in the
current mix
okay and uh so
uh that's uh that's uh uh a recent
result with eric chastain
adil ivnath and um
michael live here at berkeley
so there is uh
another mystery in in
evolution which is variance preservation
okay
we all know you know or at least thought
we know until recently
that what you do in evolution is you try
to increase fitness okay increasing
fitness means choosing
cherry picking alleles cherry picking
alleles means that most other alleles
become extinct okay
how come we have this variation okay how
come we look at the human genome
and there is this amazing variation how
come we look at thousands of genomes
and we see astounding amount of
variation okay and variation which is
meaningful
biologically it's not not just silent
mutations
and it turns out
that there is an alternative way to look
at them of the mua okay the the
multiplicative weight updates algorithm
and this alternative way to look at it
is that it
you know not in terms of what it's doing
we know what it's doing it's boosting
but what it tries to optimize okay
because you can see it as
you can see the its choice as
the optimum of some convex function okay
and this convex function
is the convex combination of two things
one is fitness okay the utility of the
game
and the other component of this convex
combination
is the entropy of the distribution
okay so basically what the and the point
is that some of the smaller the entropy
the smaller epsilon is
the in other words the less aggressive
your algorithm
is the the less aggressive the algorithm
is in taking into account
the the last performance of every expert
the more you cater to entropy okay you
are taking care of entropy
you are trying to to increase the
entropy of your
and that makes absolutely sense because
you want your mix of experts to have
entropy okay you don't want
an expert to monopolize your uh
your uh your mix because uh you know
that there is an adversary lurking who
is going who is going to kill you
so uh uh
so in some sense we have uh this theorem
unites two mysteries okay the surprising
success
of uh the multiplicative weight updates
algorithm
in so many fields and the surprises
success of
mutual selection okay so that's what
computer scientists uh do best okay
decrease the number of mysteries okay so
mary's mister is in the one i mean also
uh what uh
what de carp did the 23 who did did
40 years ago is he merged 23 mysteries
into one okay
of course this mystery is still
tormenting us okay you know but
but but but it's better than 23
mysteries okay so uh
good uh so this is uh you know i believe
that i really believe
and uh when i say i i mean my authors
all not all my quarters agree that uh
this is the role of sex and evolution so
we know to you know
to enable the multiplicative weight
update algorithm
all right so
i hope i showed you that that i gave you
a glimpse of
the amazing problems that that that you
can encounter if you start thinking
about about the
theory of life one thing that i wanted
to
to warn you is that it's uh
like everybody else i have been using
evolution in my everyday talk
uh you know 10 years ago
a lot and and
sort of you know when i when i started
thinking and reading about it
uh i realized the sort of you know how
naive i was sort of you know with my my
thought about evolution so you know it's
a much much more sophisticated subject
a much deeper subject than
the survival of the fitness okay
so it's full of uh
technically interesting problems and uh
some of them turn out to be in a very
unexpected way to computational
okay uh there are many questions all
right i know this is uh this is
sort of you know i really see this as
the beginning of of things at the
beginning of a computer science they're
thinking of evolution
how robust are these results uh
i sort of know the answer the answer is
not at all okay so we know that that
that we i i sketch
our assumptions and every assumption
was painful and necessary
okay so so so we know that
mathematically these things don't hold
beyond our assumptions okay uh but
still sort of you know the our
conclusions are robust or there must be
some there must be some more clever
mathematical theory okay that
that that encompasses this and many
others all right
uh and of course uh we have not talked
about uh
perhaps the most interesting aspects
which are environmental mutations
uh i can explain to you why sort of we
have not talked about this
the reason is that
i feel as a newcomer
okay sorry no to this field uh and
uh a new camera under scrutiny and i'm
not saying i welcome newcomer but so you
know and unders very severe scrutiny
okay and uh i thought that my best way
sort of you know to
gain a decent entry would be by
by by uh sticking to uncontroversial
mathematical models okay so you know
models that everybody accepts okay
nobody accepts a standard model for the
environment nobody accepts a standard
model for mutations okay so that's
that's uh that's a barrier
has been a barrier until now but maybe
not no more
and of course these are theories okay
theories should be falsifiable
how do you falsify these theories right
so that's that's uh
that's a great question okay so thank
you very much
yeah i don't know if you want to get
into this right now but
we should repeat questions all right so
um so
zero sum games we know that
multiplication of the weight updates
work okay
how about uh how about other games
they don't okay in general games
in coordination games they do work and
and the
the the potential function is the common
utility
what does it mean for um what does it
even mean to play such a game
oh it means exactly that that that you
that you that you that you
uh you see what everybody else is doing
so remember you are cognitively
completely challenged okay you cannot
see
that uh six okay everybody or six okay
so
you know which everybody in every game
would do you are you are a gene
right i mean you are you are a gene in
an organism all right so
what you what you do is you look at how
every every allele of yours did in the
current mix
and you boost it okay
so incidentally the amount by which you
boost it is essentially
the mixability of this allele
in some sense this is sort of you know a
mathematical verification of what i told
you before by simulations about
mixability
mark when you have some uh
yes yes of course of course so so
mark mazar is asking uh what happens if
epsilon is not infinitesimal
it doesn't have to be the intestine has
to be smaller essentially than one over
the population okay i know so
so uh you really need the huge
populations
for you know for for because there are
finite population effects
uh uh there is genetic drift and
suddenly
a bad idea has been fixed and goodbye
good idea okay so yes that's actually
true so there are
this is one of the many incidentally the
model i presented
assumes infinite population okay so so
and
you know and uh of course it's it's uh
it's
uh unrealistic okay so but it's uh
it's one of the many unrealistic
assumptions that you have to do in order
to get there
okay so so it's i consider this as
some interesting new tracks to try
mathematical tracks to travel in
evolution
and there is much more interesting work
than this and much more generally
working on this
that way thanks yes
berkeley working on the theory of
crystalline variation
thank you very much for thank very much
for this point
many things i mean the comment was about
a theory which i'm ashamed to say i have
not
developed here at berkeley which i'm
ashamed to say i'm not familiar with
or facilitated variation which uh
it's music to my ears i know that the
terms sound exactly what i want to read
okay so
i will not hold you against him
thank you
90 of the species died out so
maybe the problem is that environment
isn't controllable
or it doesn't doesn't follow laws that
you can
perceive there so if the environment is
vastly changing then things are
different
absolutely so yeah so uh
the the cambrian explosion which which
of course uh
good uh uh emphasized in his work
is was uh sort of you know it created
the variation that we know now but
and who knows
what were what were what what was uh
what were what were the precise
parameters and laws that were governing
evolution back then okay so you know
the and and the
uh you know another another another
concept uh tossed by gould was
punctuated equilibria
which basically means that
essentially there is a cambrian
explosion
where there is some kind of jerk and
then there is a nice
uh continuous and then maybe there is
something else i mean a
meteorite hits who knows so and then
there is
and of course i deep in my heart i
believe that
the reason why variation is maximized
i repeat through the multiplicative
weight updates algorithm evolution
is because uh we want to be ready about
for for for changes in environment okay
but our model says that
it's done okay so you know not does say
for what purpose right so then
so how chromosomes are organized and so
i'm wondering if you have any thoughts
on the role of space
in computation
so uh you know unfortunately
what i could display on on the screen
was
two genes on two chromosomes right so uh
of course i mean chromosome chromosomes
and linkage and
and and and recombination uh probability
and so on are paramount okay
i should mention that uh our results
hold
as long as there is some recombination
probability in other words you don't
recognize we don't require complete
recombination let's say r equals half
for it i mean
if there is positive if there is
positive r that's that's that's good
enough
okay that's uh that enables the
mathematic the mathematics that we use
uh and uh
uh listen i mean although so there are
there are
uh this you know the theory as i
presented it is so
abstract and stylized okay so you know
that
of course it shoves under the rag all of
biology okay including the chromosomes
including sort of you know the
uh everything else in the genome
including
proteins peptides and so on you know of
course yeah
so i'm not i'm not
happy about that so you know but but i
don't see on literature
you said that you believe that it's
optimizing its ability to take into
account variation in the environment
have you have you looked at the idea
that that maybe there's maybe a
complicated
reason i'm struck by a connection to a
lot of release of literature and
approximation algorithm
where if your competition limited the
best thing is to kind of solve your
program
and spit out maximum entropy rounding
of the solution and if your computation
limited that turns out to be the best
thing you can do
might there be something similar going
on here
uh so i'm not sure okay because because
the point of evolution is not to round
okay it's not to select an allele
it wants to keep them all around and
very wisely
uh uh gauge the their probabilities
okay uh so i mean it would be amazing if
we could if we could uh
uh uh connect uh
you know so i'm delighted that
that we were able to connect to
evolution multiplicative weights update
it would be amazing if we could like
connect with some of the brilliant
algorithms we are using
in for example in approximation
algorithms
professor ziegler yeah that's you had a
question or not
uh is i believe so yes so
uh so i mean i i didn't pound my chest
yeah but
but uh i i i i
i i think that that that in all this
sort of you know
there is there is some all of all of
what
all of what i said uh has sex as a
prerequisite okay so you know that
incidentally every time i mention sex i
see an awkward smile on your faces okay
you know so this means that you are not
evolutionary biologists okay
so for evolutionary biology
sex means only the mystery of
recombination in in evolution okay so
it took me a long time and a lot of
effort to become evolutionary biology
series
so so all all
all everything i said is impossible
without recombination
because fitness is important the
variation is important that's the only
way to
to to maximize both
that's that's what you should do to
maximize both
and by god you can't do it okay so you
know with this stupid mechanism okay so
it's amazing that this this is what you
know and
and in other words it will be it will be
a pity if uh not all
ingredients of this mechanism particular
sex which is the most basic
were not around and we could not run
this this this uh
this miraculous algorithm so you know
even though we are just keeping genes
sensing uh getting very very faulty
feedback
okay do i make sense
yes of course of course because because
you know so the question is are is is
variation in conflict with fitness of
course it is
because uh fitness is what the sexual
maximize is what the sexual organs would
do pick the best combination and stick
with it forever okay
but here you prepare you prepare a soup
okay
which you manipulate by this algorithm
okay so that's uh
okay really last question okay yes
why do you want a single maximization
point couldn't it be that you have two
very different
optimal points where they're exactly the
same
force for the wife and player
it will also help to increase energy so
it should be in an evolutionary terms
where the maximum
for variability equilibrium with maximum
number of different equivalent points
should be
stable uh so so in some sense we are not
in this agreement i mean that this is
this is what's happening you know that
that what i'm saying is that
is that of course if this happens uh you
know the
orga you know the the species is very
lucky if that
that's the shape of its landscape if it
has a lot of
a lot of uh equally high mountains on
its landscape
but what i'm saying is that is that uh
uh
there is a mechanism the multiple
negative weight updates
are mechanisms or or no regretted
learning which
achieves the same effect in much more
rough landscapes it's much
much more uneven landscapes